تزداد الهجمات على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كثافه وتعقيدا استفاقت العاصمه اليوم على
هجمه مكثفه بالمسيرات الانتحاريه هي
السابعه عشر منذ شهر مايو فقط منذ بدايه
هذا الشهر تتعرض العاصمه لهجمات مكثفه
بالمسيرات وبالصواريخ واحيانا بشكل متزامن
هذا الموقع هو احد المواقع الذي تعرض لضرر
كبير وقتل فيه شخص واصيب عدد اخر من
السكان ايضا قبل ان يتم اجلاء السكان من
هذا المبنى الذي تعرض لاضرار بالغه تقول
السلطات الاوكرانيه انها اسقطت عشرات
المسيرات التي وجهت نحو العاصمه
الاوكرانيه خلال هذه الهجمه المكثفه
بالمسيرات التي اتت بعد
هجمات اخرى كانت قد تعرضت لها العاصمه
بكثافه كبيره بمعدل ثلاث هجمات خلال
ساعه الاخيره فقط وهذا اتى بعد سلسله من
الهجمات ايضا نحو العاصمه تقول السلطات
الاوكرانيه انها تخشى من استنزاف الدفاعات
الجويه في ظل هذه الهجمات المكثفه
بالمسيارات وبانواع مختلفه ومن الاتجاهات
مختلفه ايضا من الصواريخ وفي ذات الوقت
فانها تؤكد انها تتعامل مع الاهداف الجويه
التي يتم توجيهها واستهداف العاصمه
الاوكرانيه بها نشاهد هذه الاضرار انما
ايضا في مواقع اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من
العاصمه الاوكرانيه ايضا كان هناك اضرار
مشابهه
لمناطق سقط فيها اما مسيرات او حطام
للمسيارات التي اسقطتها الدفاعات الجويه
حسن مسعود الجزيره
كيف